attention le 28 mars début du compte à
rebours un gang de professionnels
surentraînés emmenés par un chef sans
scrupule a décidé de prendre d'assaut la
tour montparnasse blanc duc thinh 50
millions ils sont prêts à tout pour y
arriver
désormais pour les otages les minutes
sont comptées rien ni personne ne peut
les arrêter
tout est sous contrôle l'accueil des
verrouillages mais certains éléments
sont incontrôlables
or
on
face à eux banque de laveur de carreaux
gros maigres et un petit show l'objectif
qu'est ce qu'il ya encore ça fait deux
fois j'ai nettoyé de foyers alors deux
fois deux fois après ce héros 50
millions de spectateurs
et les hommes s'ils tendent
la tour montparnasse infernale la
tournée peut-être viser entre des
casques
cascades papa personne ne bouge à des
effets spéciaux
sinon je tire une balle dans la tête à
la main très spéciaux les costumes
très lourd
des acteurs internationaux
tu fais des explosions
des trucs qui colle placer des frais
chinois
les scènes chaudes je crois que nous
avons affaire à des professionnels
j'étais promis que j'allais les dépenses
et un par un eh ben c'est ce que je fais
à la tour montparnasse infernale matrix
le 28 mars
sacré poursuites